and they did well too yeah even Brad
Brad was honestly on bro but I was
[ __ ] on Backstage but he had his own
things to deal with but Carlos beautiful
he set the tone dad he's a psychopath
bro he's a cycle bro you know his whole
shit's [ __ ] up did you explain what
he's talking about there's a moment the
guy the guy um he's fighting his uh yes
he's a Peruvian Prince or something he's
a leg lock specialist right he's had
like three knee bars in the UFC so he
goes at Dan Rice Street that's why he
starts doing the butt scoot and all that
[ __ ]
double pull glass it was trying to bump
off Dan yeah he got him in the first
round I think that's what Uncle Joe does
when he says
that was really funny
so the guy holds his leg gets his leg uh
I think he had him in the ankle lock so
many different things with a completely
straight no he had an echo lock at one
point and then he had a knee bar and
then Dan's sitting there and you see
homeboy like pulling cranking cranking I
thought it was done
you see him do this
[Laughter]
you dad's not reacting so is he actually
doing anything yeah he was not so damn
and even David told me after the fight
because Dan did a interview with
freestyle bender and I when I was
watching the fight I was like this
reminds me of Dan's debut because Dan
fought this guy
um who's a leg lock specialist same
thing ankle locks everyone in the UFC
and Dan Fordham the guy took his legs
and danced that's bendy he's bendy as
[ __ ] it's so flexible and he was able to
beat the guy and [ __ ] him up from that
position and then eventually finished
him but David said in that interview Dan
said to himself at his UFC debut in
Auckland
if this guy gets to my legs and he
cranks
Dan made an agreement with himself to
just let it go like okay he's gonna
break my legs cool
not only he's a psych I've been saying
this for so long do you think I'm joking
I Know Dan when you when you train with
someone for so many years and you hang
out with them you know them on a
different level he's a psychopath like
the New Zealand psychopath so yeah he
his shit's [ __ ] up I don't know what
it is ankle me ACL all that he's walking
around today he's fine and he was he was
on one this morning I won't even get
into that wait a minute
[Laughter]
[ __ ] State Building but um yeah so
his old shit's [ __ ] up he didn't tap
he just sat there just like cool my
shit's [ __ ]
absolutely it's cold bro yeah and then
gets up stabs the guy but the guy I mean
he doesn't want to smoke bro yeah and
the Dan stabs you he even in training
you're supposed to do a light to your
spine points like I see y'all go at it I
see y'all go man that have some
Pay-Per-View fights bro
Jeff's got all the video yeah was that
lit up was that like a kick to the liver
yeah either to the sternum or to the
liver the liver is right here yeah so
he'll he'll he'll make his tour like a
spear just pull it up and then jam it
right through you'd be surprised all
right you haven't been liver shop before
you feel that yeah you feel the pain
it's like it's gone it's the only time I
got sat down where I had I sat myself
like I've been hit hard just kind of
sparring and then I'd be like oh chill
chill chill chill chill yeah but with
the liver I got hit and I was like all
right we good yeah two steps and then I
just I I go hold the [ __ ]
[ __ ] like take five steps and then you
yeah it's an involuntary body response
your whole body just shuts down and it's
just like protect everything so your
body just like it I've been I've had it
before so I know what the feeling is
actually a dance stabbed him stabbed him
and then he got back up and I was like
come on ref if he goes down again I'm
glad the ref called a fight yeah yeah
because you could see that they didn't
want it after that but it was cool to
see Dan get that done yeah same and then
those post fight on the mic
yeah yeah so this is good man so good I
know you guys are big on team and
everything like that so